valérie benaïm je sais pas si vous le
saviez mais votre sosie travaille dans
une pâtisserie chez bon temps à paris
regardez le sodi qu'on nous envoyait
c'est le même phénomène miles sauf
qu'elle elle fait des éclairs au café
elle elle fait des makrouts c'est pareil
mais bahamas en voilà elles vont elles
pas pas mal non c'est les yeux des yeux
j'avais dans les oreilles les cheveux
matthieu delormeau brad pitt on a déjà
fait non c'est pas de bol c'est vrai les
gens nous envoyer ça ouais sauf que lui
il a un petit blond vénitien
ah oui oui il n'ya pas de même bien
effectivement parce qu'il a pas blond
cendré
c'est ce que j'ai fait aujourd'hui ms
bon vous avez coupé sur les photos qu'on
n'a pas moi c'est régine taussat avait
alors onze jeunes aujourd'hui j'ai fait
donc j'ai coupé
j'ai fait un colleur five sur les côtés
un colleur five oui absolument pour les
cheveux blancs au dessus j'ai fait une
couleur mais n'est pas musulmane déco
mais j'ai pas mis de patine pour pas que
ça des gorges de soleil et j'ai corrigé
pas un fond d'une gorge au soleil soleil
si on fait le coup une patine et qu'on
entretient mal derrière ça des gorges au
soleil savannah cheveux très jaune
il fait pas beau ça dégouline la couleur
vire à l a bien fait pas peur car que ce
soit pas bout qui dirait qu on ne sent
rien deuxième choisi de vous un peu plus
rastkhah c'est helmut couche commencer
un jour
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
division 2 allemande s'appelle helmut
kohl eu chaud mais moi je la trouve sur
les dents et on viendra à ne pas
s'appeler elle est née le contraire
c'est un mélange trop gilles verdez et
l'accueil de l'en but c'est vrai qu'ils
n'ont pas bougé oui il vous plaît je ne
veux pas m'y plie changement vous fait
le ramadan du sexe ou quoi elle a une
ode al salam à faire des compromis comme
c'est sa came
non ils ne t'ont pas déplaisant et je
vais vous faire un test ophtalmologiques
way lui les causes bruel mou de couchage
ai pas dit qu'ils étaient morts quand
j'ai dit qu'il n'était pas déplaisant a
du charme mais celle du charme ou
dracula l'oeil qui pétille
[Rires]
alors où nous arriverons également royal
celui de kanye benno béni à y perdre le
font ils peur bleue faut regarder quels
sont les madame c'est pas moi c'est
bercy mais c'est sympa pour être maman
comme elle s'appelle votre nom l'europe
laurence m'en excuse alors en soirée
c'est plus calme c'est kelly qu'elle
m'allait a beaucoup d'encre
c'est qu'elle est à malabo bizarre il
est drôle celui-ci il est drôle celui-ci
il est très drôle
alors à qui on a un sosie de keen'v
aussi regarder au nom c'est ce que nous
ont envoyé les twittos connu l'adhésion
directe à leur égard ouais c'est bien
mais les vikings des méningiomes j'ai
amené les oreilles aux régions on est
bien y'a rien il est magnifique c'est un
ancien pompier les gaules et de la mort
il a fait saillant dans oui bah je suis
désolé non vie validaient ancien pont
piéton oui ça c'est grave makam quoi
c'est vrai à laurence gola est ce que
voulait peut-être simulé un malaise et
il veut pouvoir fait un mois qu'il
attend ce alors à leurs yeux mais je
vais vous annoncer de mauvaises
nouvelles
ouais asie et virer le 20 juin c'est ma
dernière
elle sera pas la peine de revenir
l'année prochaine oh mon dieu je me sens
là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ne pouvait mec les pompiers c'est que
quand tu fais pas là quand tu fais pas
la moisissure à ta couche en fait quand
t'as pas fait la la la la mise à jour tu
peux plus faire voilà bah voilà c'est
pas la même chose
allez allez vous attaquant dimanche est
à dégorger c'est bien d'abord il est en
forme quand ils dorment pas il est au
top alors pas dormi on aa
on a souvent varié le badge à tout le
monde dit sur twitter que vous êtes
sosie de quelqu'un ici sérieux ouais
sans rigoler tout le monde l'a comparé
bas regarder non je ne trouve pas ses
critiques à rien et il ya des deux pas
un truc c'est que quand on sourit lui et
moi on a un point commun le nez des 100
ha
je suis comme ça il est normal et si je
fais ça ou ab savez sans toi si je me
bats aussi oui bonsoir j'ai le sosie
officiel de
jimmy mohlala sosie que celle de jimmy
c'est la production peut trouver à un
personnage qui s'appelle brique dans la
série the middle we call of
mais son sosie officiel comme à trouver
briques à l'oeuvre dans la série the
middle jean michel maire on s'en
souvient il était venu sur le plateau
c'est patrick le mec de dennebroeucq
d'ailleurs jouable et là dessus on
entend de plus en plus tu rigoles qui
fait le foot
oui mais non oui oui non non là vous de
l'acier n'importe quoi à l'époque gynéco
a reçu un seau dit aussi dudognon
akouala c'est un bonnet a alors les
chéris on a également je vous dis on a
reçu une photo du sosie
une saisie de deux papas de base et en
moto c'est pas nous sur l'hypnose qu'il
nous envoyer une photo du sosie doit
être pas mal que j'adore oui on parle
bien de mon père donc on adore voilà des
corses et pantalons sur les
téléspectateurs alors malheureusement je
sais la mort de rire le port non mais
c'est rien c'était parce que c'était
c'est vrai que nous des communes puis
rue que dans l'aude fabrice était bondée
on a même une photo de vous avec avec
votre père avec vous réunis regardez
regardez
mais c'est sûr qu'il ya un truc à bas
les yeux regarde alors mais c'est vrai
que les yeux les yeux ce sont les mêmes
c'est moi quand même là
alors les séries live on le dit elle a
les yeux plus ouvertes ou plus et mieux
enfin mais non mais non mais non
benjamin à moi je te vois pas comme un
castaldi pendant l'émission parfois s'il
vous plaît vous me direz et on a aussi
quelqu'un qui a vu le sosie de patrick
sébastien regarder le sosie de patrick
sébastien se dit patrick sébastien c'est
en train de se référer je vous le dis
mon préfet rythme
il a deux d'abord alors il ya aussi le
sosie de zinedine zidane
regardez ce dîner d'in stat oui mais
voilà on peut le respecte et d'ailleurs
on nniversaire nom a enjoint à pipe et
bien sûr lembras et je serai là et il ya
le sosie de zlatan ibrahimovic
regardez c'est mon préféré
non
mais l'ufc zaman ibrahimovic il était
prof de musique sans déconner c'est
exactement